Pope Francis in Estonia today address a
worldwide sex abuse scandals rocking the
Catholic Church the pontiff said the
crisis is driving people away he
insisted that the church must change if
it's to keep future generations today
Pennsylvania lawmakers are expected to
vote on sweeping legislation to give
child sex abuse victims more time to
seek justice for crimes committed
against them in August a grand jury
report detailed decades of abuse and
cover-ups by more than 300 priests in
that state at the time only two cases in
the report led to criminal charges last
night the Statehouse was lit in blue to
honor survivors dozens of them have
traveled to the Capitol to urge
legislators to pass the measure Nikki
batise is in Harrisburg and spoke to
some of them Nicki good morning good
morning the survivors fight to change
the laws here in Pennsylvania gained
momentum after last month's landmark
grand jury report and a child sex abuse
in the Catholic Church almost all of
those cases are now too old for civil or
criminal charges and bipartisan
legislators want to change that Judgment
Day is upon us and this legislation will
Pennsylvania state representative Mark
Rossi understands Catholic clergy sex
abuse victims in a way very few
politicians can he says his priests
raped him when he was 13 years old being
a victim of child sex abuse has changed
my entire life
Razi is leading the fight for what
victims call the window to justice
giving them a two year period to file
civil lawsuits if their claims are
already barred by the statute of
limitations they can go in there
identify their perpetrator and also get
compensation for the egregious crimes
committed against them some opponents
argue that retroactive window may
violate Pennsylvania's Constitution I am
therefore unable to support the
amendment as much as I would like to the
House overwhelmingly passed Rosie's plan
yesterday a broader package of reforms
is scheduled for vote today including
eliminating the statute of limitations
in criminal cases and giving survivors
up to the age of 50 to file civil suit
they need to do what is right Brian
O'Connor says he was sexually abused by
his priest when he was 10 years old he
came all the way from Pittsburgh to
March with other survivors hoping to
convince lawmakers to pass the bill I
need them to ask themselves one question
what if I was their son how would they
feel done
that legislation is expected to pass in
the house here later today but Mark
Rossi says the real battle will be in
the Senate we did speak with
Pennsylvania's governor who told us if
the bill makes it to his desk he will
sign it
John nikki batiste thanks